the environment is a is you know a huge
issue that I think we all can do our
part in solving the disarray that that
power is being thrown around in the
world is really terrifying and you know
and and then very selfishly and and very
self-involved in our own in the USA just
sort of what you know fads are and and
escapism is really fascinating what
people use to what people find humorous
what people find the what have what
things people use to distract themselves
from from sort of the chaotic time I
don't believe that we're living at a
time necessarily that's that has more
conflicts than in ancient past history I
think there are many cultures and
civilizations changing but I think that
because the world has gotten so small
and communication is so fast that it
creates everything on a much larger
scale the worlds in communication at all
moments all around where you know it's
an orb around and orb of communication
it's not point to point
I think the largest challenge you know
ahead you know it will definitely be to
see how every person individually you
know in this time of individual style
can can affect the environment and and
remember that they have their own voice
that every voice matters I think
challenges of the u.s. um are you know
first off you know I think the greatest
challenge of the u.s. right now is is is
creek is having their eyes open and
creating dialogue with with the rest of
the orb and then second and then you
know looking within its own land and
figuring out a system you know that
supports growth in a healthy way for its
people and evolution doesn't you know
things don't have to be new they just
have to evolve and grow and then
preservation of its own country and own
culture you know if we were a very
short-lived country it was a different
form before before and so you know I
think it's very important for people to
listen to each other in the country
I think you know international relations
or you know are an enormous issue right
now I think the environment has to be a
huge issue you know you know the United
States you know through through
economics is a huge you know powerful
force and a huge contributor to
pollution I believe that you know I
think those are really the two largest
issues for me and and have people I
think it's really important for effort
is is for for clarity and brevity and
speak people being very straight forward
a it's it's very frustrating to believe
in a system that is so convoluted and
and trying to be manipulative with with
without using really visceral song and
dance
you